Tywin Lannister: The Westerlands are all bounded
by three natural defenses.
Mountain, sea, and forest.
Necessary barriers when the land is as rich
as ours.
From our mines come the gold and silver that
fuel the rest of Westeros.
From Lannisport, our largest city, come the
most skillful gold and silversmiths in the
land.
Yet, geography alone is not strength.
The Westerlands would have been sacked and
pillaged for thousands of years if it had
not been for the men who ruled it.
My family.
House Lannister.
According to legend, we trace their descent
to Lann the Clever, a trickster of the Dawn
Age, who swindled the Casterlys out of Casterly
Rock, their ancient castle.
A childish story, but not without merit.
One, a mind can and should be a weapon in
a man's arsenal.
Two, Lann must've been clever enough not to
rely solely on his wits.
After all, where today is House Casterly?
Three, by keeping the Casterly name on the
castle, Lann reminded the world of the price
of getting in his way.
The Reynes ignored all these lessons.
Not content with being the second-richest
family, they sought to challenge the first:
mine.
My father had put up with their insults and
disrespect.
When I came of age, I led our army to teach
them what they should have known.
Some people say I was too harsh, that eradicating
every member of their family was not necessary.
But now there are no bannermen as loyal to
their lord as the Westerlands to us.
If any lord bridles at our authority, I have
only to send a singer with a harp, and he
falls back into line.
Fools look at the Westerlands and see gold.
Fools see our wealth and call it strength.
Gold is just another rock.
The Westerlands are strong because of House
Lannister.
From strong leadership comes unity.
From unity comes power.
Jaime Lannister:My ancestor, King Loren of
House Lannister, was head of the wealthiest
family in the Seven Kingdoms.
When King Loren joined his forces to Mern
of House Gardener, King of the Reach, they
had the mightiest army in history, a so-called
iron fist to break the would-be conqueror.
But while an iron fist can smash a man's face
in battle, you'd look silly hunting birds
or beasts with it, and Aegon had a creature
that was both.
The kings had never even seen a dragon, let
alone fought one.
They had fought each other for thousands of
years, and victory always went to the larger
army.
Surely a force five times that of Aegon's
could manage one dragon.
But Aegon arrived with three.
Still, the Lannisters and Gardeners hoped
for victory.
The battlefield they chose was a wide plain
with firm ground and clear skies.
Perfect for archers and mounted cavalry.
But neither of the kings spared a thought
for why the ground was firm.
There had been no rain for a fortnight, which
meant all the wheat and grass on it were bone-dry.
Perfect for dragons.
At first, the kings looked like they would
emerge victorious.
When the horn blew for battle, their armies
swept around Aegon's flanks, and their iron
fist of mounted knights smashed through his
center before the dragons could even enter
the fray.
But then Aegon and his sisters took flight
and unleashed their dragons, not on the soldiers,
but on the dry fields all around them.
The iron fist unclenched and became a hand
outstretched for mercy.
As Aegon promised, he had none.
More than four thousand men died in the fires,
another thousand escaping them.
Tens of thousands returned home as monsters,
burned and scarred beyond recognition.
House Gardener never returned at all.
The Field of Fire, as the singers call it,
claimed the last of the Gardener line, and
House Tyrell rose in their stead as Lords
of the Reach and Wardens of the South.
As for my illustrious ancestor, when King
Loren saw the battle was lost, he rode through
a wall of flame and smoke to safety.
Or at least to a heroic capture a day later,
where he lay his sword before Aegon and knelt.
Aegon, true to his word, spared him and confirmed
House Lannister as Lords of Casterly Rock
and Wardens of the West.
Why wouldn't he?
A Lannister always pays his debts, and now
we owed our lives to the crown.
That was worth centuries of subservience,
at least.
Besides, Aegon had a fetish for collecting
swords, not heads.
He added Loren's to the pile his men had retrieved
from the Field of Fire and sent them back
to the Aegonfort.
Petyr Baelish: Years later, the realm had
no sharper mind than Lord Tywin Lannister,
Hand to King Aerys II Targaryen, or as history
remembers him, "The Mad King."
He saw assassins and plots in every shadow,
heard whispers in silence, and burned men
alive, but his greatest madness by far was
driving away Lord Tywin.
The Mad King then cycled through every mistake
of his ancestors.
Soldiers, toadying lords and at the end, even
an alchemist, perhaps to save the crown's
growing expenses on wildfire.
Unfortunately, it didn't save his crown or
his dynasty.
Tywin Lannister: As Aerys Targaryen's behavior
grew more and more erratic, the task of ruling
the Seven Kingdoms fell to me, Tywin Lannister.
I had served Aerys for nearly twenty years
and as a result, the realm had prospered.
The royal coffers were full, the land was
at peace.
But Aerys grew increasingly hostile, jealous
of the success many credited to me.
My power and influence unnerved him.
The captain of my personal guard, Ser Ilyn
Payne, was once overheard making offhand comments
regarding who was the true ruler of Westeros.
When the king was given this information,
he had llyn Payne's tongue ripped out with
hot pincers.
It was my desire to unite the Houses of Lannister
and Targaryen through marriage.
My daughter, Cersei, would marry Aerys's eldest
son, Prince Rhaegar.
Such a union made perfect sense for all parties.
However, Aerys's senses had begun to leave
him quite sometime earlier.
Instead of uniting the royal family with its
most loyal and powerful ally, Aerys chose
instead to insult my family, indicating that
such a match was beneath Rhaegar.
Instead, he chose Elia Martell of Dorne to
be Rhaegar's wife.
As if to rub salt in my wounds, Aerys appointed
Jaime, my son, to the Kingsguard.
The Kingsguard may be an honor for lesser
families than ours, but it is a lifetime appointment
that forces him to renounce all family holdings.
This creates a difficulty in naming an heir
to Casterly Rock.
But Aerys knew all that.
I had grown tired of the king's constant provocation.
Thus I resigned my post as Aerys's Hand and
returned to Casterly Rock with my considerable
forces.
When Robert Baratheon rebelled against the
throne, Aerys grew fearful that I would join
with Robert's forces and rise against him.
He thought himself clever and kept Jaime very
close as if warning me.
He sunk deeper and deeper into delusion, paranoia,
and violence.
Rhaegar Targaryen lay dead on the banks of
the Trident, his royal army shattered and
in retreat.
The days of the dragon kings were clearly
numbered.
Until that moment it would have been foolish
to commit Casterly Rock to either the crown
or the rebellion.
What would House Lannister have to gain in
supporting a raving madman or in entering
a crusade to put Robert Baratheon on the Iron
Throne?
But chaos benefits no one.
It was time for House Lannister to do what
it could to ensure a return of peace and prosperity
to the land.
I, Tywin Lannister, brought ten thousand Lannister
troops to the gates of King's Landing, in
order to bring the bloodshed to a quick and
decisive conclusion.
King Aerys had been sending ravens for months
begging for my support to end the uprising.
In a way, his pleas had been answered.
As I had suspected, Aerys opened the city
gates and welcomed my men.
Our plan was clear: crush Aerys's remaining
bannermen and remove the remnants of the royal
family as quickly and efficiently as possible.
Any alternative meant years of further war
and a fragmented Seven Kingdoms.
Our means were bloody, but the results speak
for themselves.
As for Aerys, it is true he met his fate at
the hands of my son.
Aerys had kept Jaime close during the rebellion,
thinking himself clever in keeping my son
as a hostage - should I decide to pledge support
to the rebel cause.
This proved to be his greatest mistake, for
when the time came Jaime did his duty as a
Lannister... and drove his sword into the
Mad King's back.
Jaime Lannister:My father's knights burst
into the hall in time to see the last of it,
so there was no way for me to vanish and let
some bragger steal the glory or blame.
I knew at once when I saw the way they looked
at me.
It would be blame.
Lannister or no, I'd been one of Aerys' Kingsguard.
I commanded them to announce that the Mad
King was dead and to spare all those who yielded.
They asked me if they should proclaim a new
king as well.
I knew what they meant.
Would it be my father, or Robert Baratheon,
or maybe the child Viserys who'd fled to Dragonstone?
A Targaryen boy king with my father as Hand
to rule in truth.
I thought of how Ned Stark and Robert Baratheon
would howl at this end to their great heroic
war, and I was tempted.
Then I glanced down again at Aerys, his life's
blood oozing from the wound and pooling on
the floor around him.
"Proclaim who you bloody well like," I said.
I climbed the steps to the Iron Throne and
sat on it with my sword across my knees, waiting
to see who would come to claim the kingdom.